hello everyone and welcome to this
session of blockchain tutorial part 1 my
name is Sarah and I am part of the
simple learn team so let's get started
and understand what's in it for us today
so let's take in hypothesis in a city
not so far away
somebody was up to something bad so
there's a hacker who hits bang who wants
to steal the money
of all the people lying in the bank now
here's why I hate them even more what
are the nuances and the problem areas of
the banking system the banking system
has higher transactional and
international transfer costs a lot of
documentation is required for setting up
of an account for opening an account and
onboarding a customer and the banking
system is not always accessible it's not
24 by 7 it's closed on banking holidays
and it has other limitations also like
transfer limits in a day and you know
you can't transfer X amount within a
stipulated time now Bank in the
ecosystem acts as a center point of
failure
it is a centralized based system which
is prone to failure from a centralized
point of view so if the bank fails all
the transactions will come to an halt
which are dependent on the bank let's
see what happens if the hacker is able
to get into the banking system and hack
the bank all the investors or the people
associated with the bank the information
associated with them will get corrupted
will get jeopardized and it can lead to
huge losses to the bank and to the
individuals and all this can happen with
a click of a button it's as simple as
that
so once a hacker has access to the
system he can manipulate the system
compromise information share it with the
parties which are not supposed to have
that information and lot can go wrong
though the hackers can be caught right
it is possible through cybersecurity and
various means but once the information
is compromised it is very difficult to
roll that back and that's why we need
more secure systems and systems which
are not dependent on a centralized
Authority which work in a more
decentralized fashion where by making it
hack truth plus lowering the transaction
cost also now this
of course when you catch the bank
managers attention now he will go to his
advisers and want to make sure this does
not happen again so technology come
people the advisers will make sure that
this does not happen but what is the
remedy so the remedy is setting up a
block now of course the manager who is
looking under the banking functions
might not be aware of the technology and
what benefits blockchain bring onto the
table in order to prevent such an
incident so that's what we are here for
we will learn before we go and
understand what can blockchain actually
achieve for us so we will understand
today what is blockchain the Bitcoin
story the features of blockchain like
public distributed ledger the hashing
encryption the proof of work consensus
algorithm and the concept of mining and
then we will cover up a use case where
how blockchain can be used for banking
operations now what is blockchain
blockchain is a list of Records called
blocks which stores data publicly and in
a chronological order and the entire
information is persisted using
cryptography it is secured using
cryptography so cryptography ensures
that the privacy of the user is
maintained and data cannot be altered
information on a blockchain network is
not controlled by a centralized
authority for unlike modern financial
institutions nobody controls the data
within a blockchain the data is
maintained by the participants of the
network and they are the democratic
authority in order to approve any
transaction which can happen on a
blockchain network access to anyone on
the network
so a typical blockchain network is a
public blockchain so as long as you have
access to the network you have access to
the data within the blockchain if you
are a participant on the blockchain
network you will have the same copy of
the ledger which all other participants
have so therefore everyone every
participant on the network has the same
copy of the data so everyone in the
network has a copy of the blockchain
data which is used for ensuring the data
remains untempered so even if one node
or data on one particular participant
computer gets corrupted the other
participants will come to know
immediately
that this particular instance or node
has gone corrupted and they will rectify
it as soon as possible so basically the
question is is this the same technology
that Bitcoin works on and the answer is
yes Bitcoin could not have been possible
without blockchain so we will understand
how Bitcoin adopted blockchain in order
to reach to its journey today so Bitcoin
was introduced in 2009 by someone or a
group of people known as Satoshi
Nakamoto it aimed to solve the problem
faced by fiat currencies with the help
of blockchain technology now as of today
in 2018 there are more than 1,600 crypto
currencies that follow the concepts of
Bitcoin and blockchain for example the
other popular cryptocurrencies are like
etherium light coin - ripple and many
more now let me explain how a Bitcoin
transaction works the cinder transmits
the transaction details worldwide
basically whenever a sender has to do a
transaction he has to send bitcoins to a
receiver he will submit the transaction
on the public blockchain network of
Bitcoin and transmitted notification to
authenticate users it is done by the
miners around the world so basically
there are specific participants in the
Bitcoin network which are falling as
miners whose job is to verify the
authenticity of the sender and the
receiver and also validate whether the
sender has the right amount of valence
for the Bitcoin which he is trying to
send to the receiver
and ensuring that the sanity of the
underlying blockchain network to the
Bitcoin remains correct and not get
corrupted so once the miner has
authenticated the transaction verified
all the parameters the transaction is
added to a block and then that block is
made part of the main blockchain once
the block is added to the blockchain the
money the transactions which were
associated in the block then gets
executed money is deducted from the
sender's wallet and is added to the
receiver wallet thereby once the
transaction is completed the block is
added and the Ledger's across all the
nodes are updated each and every
participant ledger copy is updated with
the particular block which has been
added in the blockchain so therefore
all the participants have the same copy
of the information now so what makes
rock change special now these are the
special four features of blockchain
which we are going to talk about in
detail
it is a public distributed ledger it
works using a hashing encryption each
and every block has a hash value which
is the digital signature of the block
all the transactions are approved and
verified on the blockchain network using
proof-of-work consensus algorithm and
the blockchain network utilizes the
resources of the miners who are there to
validate the transaction and the miners
in lieu of putting of investing in their
resources and validating the
transactions get rewards in terms of
Bitcoin and that process is called
mining now public distributed ledger so
let's imagine four friends sharing a
particular document amongst each other
correct now if there was only a single
copy of that document and one of them
altered the data it may go unnoticed
however the outcome would be different
if each one of them had a copy of the
data
so therefore if each and every
participant has the same copy of the
data even if one of them changed the
data the others would find that the data
does not match with their own blockchain
works in a similar fashion the data
within a blockchain is accessible to
everyone
so with this as long as you are part of
the network you could access the entire
history of transactions that have taken
place since the blockchain was created
since inception and the first block in
any blockchain is called the Genesis
block so from the Genesis block to the
current block you will have the access
to the entire chain any additions to
block thing have to be approved by the
participant users in the blockchain
network so a majority of the members
within the network have to approve of
any additions to the blockchain this is
the public part of the ledger and this
is important because any additions made
to the blockchain are permanent and are
immutable so immutable transactions are
the transactions which cannot be altered
once registered they cannot be modified
and are available for audit and
vacation 24 by 7 so this means that each
and every detail is recorded and any
alterations can be detected by verifying
it against everyone's personal version
of the blockchain so if someone's tried
to modify a data on a block on a
particular node then the other Ledger's
which are having the same information
will come to know that someone has
modified data on a one particular node
and they will try to rectify it and the
fourth property no central authority is
controlling the working of this
blockchain Network it is a decentralized
Network so this is where being
decentralized hence everyone has a copy
of the blockchain which means there is
no central point of failure there is a
single source of truth even if things go
wrong the data can be recovered if one
node goes wrong the data can be
recovered from other nodes but what
about security
how is privacy maintained if everything
is so public and here hashing
encryptions comes into picture it takes
care of that so now we will talk about
the second feature which is hashing
encryption but to understand hashing
encryption we need to understand the
contents what are the contents of a
block a block in a blockchain is like a
container that holds aggregated
transactions it contains certain set of
transactions so we will see what all
things construct a particular block so a
block has two parts it has a header and
it has the second part is the
transaction details it is the set of
transactions which are aggregated in
this block now the header has following
self attributes it has the block version
number it has the hash of the previous
block to which it is linked that current
timestamp the timestamp at which the
block was verified the nonce nonce we
will see what is the attribute what is
the meaning of nonce and target value
now the transaction details are nothing
but the example which we talked about
earlier it is the transaction which the
sender and receiver are sharing the
sender is trying to send certain amount
of bitcoins from his account to the
receivers account now it is represented
in the form of a 256 bit hash value in
the header called as morkul root or the
hash root so basically the merkel root
is the hash of
all the transactions structured in a
more country called binary tree it's a
kind of a binary tree and the hash value
of the root node of the Merkel tree is
called the Merkel root hash so the
transaction details of a block are
contained in the header in a hex value
known as Merkel the Merkel root can be
calculated in this way so basically the
list of transaction each transaction is
passed through a hashing algorithm then
all the hashes of the transactions are
paired and then again passed through
another hashing algorithm until only one
value remains and which will be the root
now let me tell you how a hash function
works blockchain utilizes a hash
function to perform cryptography data
from a data set of random size is sent
as input to a hashing function to get an
encrypted value of each size and that is
the feature of any hashing function so
some unique properties of hashing
function are these are deterministic the
same input will always produce the same
hash output small changes in the data
and drastically change the output
basically they need small into the input
produces an output that's drastically
different from its previous obtained
outputs it can be computed easily the
output values can be obtained without a
whole lot of calculation and hashing
functions are one-way functions
basically you won't be able to determine
the input based on the output value so
you can't do the reverse calculation now
let's go back to our block we were
talking about earlier so as we were
discussing what are the features in the
header the previous hash is the
resultant hash of the previous block in
the blockchain and this is the way two
blocks are linked together now
transaction details these are used to
provide details about the sender
receiver and how much money they want to
exchange between them and this is a list
of transactions and they are structured
in a Merkel tree and the hash of the
merkel root is put in the header nan is
a value that is varied to create a
unique hash address of the block which
should be less than the target hash
value so this is the structure of the
head
it has a block version number basically
the sequence number of the block it has
the hash of the previous block the
timestamp when the block was mine and
verified the nonce value the header is
then this entire header is then passed
through a hashing algorithm in the case
of a Bitcoin network it is sha-256 and a
hash value is generated and now this
hash value becomes the hash value of the
block now this value is a 256 bit value
that is used to uniquely identify the
particular block so sha-256 ensures that
alterations to data can be easily
detected so for example consider these
two blocks in the blockchain they have a
similar structure and definitely
different hash values now if someone
alters the transaction details in the
first block the corresponding hash value
of the block would change to now the
values of hash value of the first block
and the previous hash value of the other
block will not match basically the block
subsequent to the hacked block will get
dealing of this would raise an alarm
among the users informing them that data
alteration has taken place the users
will then be able to flag the block for
the alteration can be easily identified
and rectified immediately to ensure
security block gain also include digital
signatures D is ensure that the message
come from the right identity right
person and that the message is not
tampered with users are provided their
own private and public key so whenever a
user onboard a public blockchain he is
provided a pair of public and private
key now private key is used by the user
to control his/her own account
this is kept as a secret by the user so
basically it is like his own password
and public key public key is used to
identify the user on the network this is
shared by the user along with the
transaction on the network for others to
verify so these are the steps involved
in creating and authenticating a digital
signature so at the sender side the
message to be transmitted is passed
through the hashing algorithm
in in this case of Bitcoin it is sha-256
and the hash is generated plus the
private key is used to generate a
digital signature now this output is
passed through a signature algorithm
along with the user's private key to
create a digital signature now during
the transmission the users message their
digital fingerprint which was generated
in the previous step plus the public key
are transmitted across the network so
these three things are published on the
network for the validators for the
miners to use and verify the
authenticity of the sender now at the
receivers end first the message is
passed through a hashing algorithm now
at the same time the sender's public key
and his or her digital signature are
passed through a very friction algorithm
now both the functions will generate a
hash if both the hashes are compared and
if they match then the transaction and
the identity of the sender is approved
otherwise it is rejected so basically
this is the process by comparing the
hash values to authenticate the identity
of the sender now what about the people
who verify these transactions and how do
they actually do it so remember that one
field in the block header called nonce
that becomes very important in order to
verify the transaction so now we will
talk about the third feature which is
the proof-of-work consensus algorithm so
proof of work involves people around the
world the participants in the network
called miners competing to be the first
one to add a block to the blockchain and
in lieu of this they will be rewarded
these are competing miners around the
world they are trying to solve a
mathematical puzzle to be the first one
to be rewarded and to add a block to the
blockchain so this is the reward so
thereby they invest in the computing
power they invest in the resources in
order to mine and validate a transaction
to get that reward now what is the
mathematical puzzle so basically they
need to find a hash value that satisfies
certain predefined conditions now in
order to find the hash value they will
use nonce so this Hoggett hash value is
decided months in advance for every
block the miners
keep very ating the nonce value to find
out an output that falls within the
target requirement so they keep on
generating a hash value using the nonce
and if it is less than the target the
hash value is accepted and if it is
greater then the hash value is rejected
the miners effort is not considered
valid now a miner transmits across the
world that he has found the nonce that
satisfies the target requirement as soon
as he find it and thanks to the hashing
algorithm used this claim can be easily
verified by others so basically the
proof-of-work algorithm it is very hard
to generate the nonce and get the hash
value but it is very easy to verify the
transaction by the other miners so
that's a whole lot of work what a
miner's payoff is so for all his or her
hard work they get paid in the bitcoins
and this is the only way the bitcoins
get added to the network sometimes they
get other forms of remuneration as well
and this is the concept of mining so
their entire process when the miner has
done the proof of work consensus they
are rewarded and this is called as miny
so mining is the process of adding a
block to the block it
this miner is the first person who found
a nonce value that fell within the
target requirement right now for doing
this the miner is rewarded as of today
on the Bitcoin network a miners fee 12.5
bitcoins for adding a block onto the
plot chain but the reward a miner gets
reduced by half every four years so when
the fourth year will approach for the
threshold the Bitcoin reward will go
down to six point two five bitcoins and
miners also get the sum of all the
transaction fees for that particular
block so the 12.5 Bitcoin reward is
justified as mining is a very expensive
process it has a heavy toll on
electricity computing power and other
resources on which the miner has
invested now we will take a look at the
use cases where blockchain is applicable
in banks so we have been incorporating a
program where banks can validate user
identity as of now a user needs to do
the
says over and over again in each Bank he
has to go and prove the identity in each
Bank is there a way we can ease the
process with blockchain and the answer
is yes we can we will be using truffle
etherium ganache and smart contracts all
of these blockchain technology ecosystem
to make it work and welcome to this demo
for how to build your kyc blockchain
application now I'm gonna show you all
the steps required to deploy your kyc
application what all components are to
be developed and how to go about
deploying and testing your application
so primarily this kyc application will
allow banks to do a decentralized kyc of
the customers which come to their banks
so in the demo we will see when AB
customer walks into the initiating bank
will do the KYC for a customer enter its
details and verify it and if any
subsequent Bank wants to use the KYC
done by another bank he or she needs to
take the permission of the customer and
then he can use the same kyc for
verification so we will see how can we
do that so just to start off with we
have developed a kyc solidity contract
which has all the necessary functions in
order to do the actions required for
doing a kyc of a particular entity by
the bank now once this contract is ready
we will be placing it in our sample
truffle package so this is my truffle
package and in this i have the contracts
folder in the contracts folder I have
kept my kyc dot sol file now in the
command prompt I will
compiled my contracts
we can ignore the warnings
so here is my ganache client which I
have just started and in my ganache
client as you can see it is running on
port 80 five four five and it has
already given me 10 accounts pre-funded
with 100 ether now i had already
mentioned that my truffle is connected
to localhost 8545 so now when I do my
truffle migrate command it will connect
to my ganache and deploy my kyc contract
so now I can go to full control and for
me it's very important to see a trick
but will address my solidity contract
has been deployed I'll copy it and in my
UI code under root J's contract details
or Jas I will make the change of this
address where my contract has now been
deployed now after doing these steps my
application is ready to interact with my
solidity contract which is being
deployed on my local blockchain network
now as you can see when I deployed the
contract this is my primary account from
which the ethers were deducted in order
to deploy the contract now there are
certain steps in order to get the
application up and running so first we
need to sign up the banks so suppose I
say bank 1 and the password should be
the first address of the bank so
basically we are associating one bank
with one account which we have on our
ATM network so we will sign up now bank
1 is successfully registered so how I
now in order to login I can check
now bank 1 I have logged in now I need
to do add a kyc for a particular
customer
you
you
you
now after filling the basic details I
will create the customer and the
username I have kept s customer one idly
this is the unique identity of the
customer it can be any social security
number or Bihar number or any unique
identity which is attached to the
customer or the email ID and can be used
as the unique identifier for the
customer now once customer profile is
successfully created we need to log in
as a customer to allow this bank to see
the KYC details now suppose if I say
customer 1 and search it it is saying at
first night and take the permission from
customer to proceed so before the bank
can do the KYC complete the customer
need to approve it so I am creating the
credentials for the customer
you
now customer can see his details
whatever we were filled by bank one and
he can see that there is a request from
bank one to allow to view his kyc now
before we allow I will also create
another Bank bank to and associated with
my another address
and try to login with it
now bank two is also logged in now bank
2 has not done the original kyc right
but it is trying to look up and it
access is also denied so it needs to
explicitly take permission so the bank
will take explicit request from the
customer so now the customer has
requests from bank 1 and bank 2 for the
KYC
it is up to the customer whether he or
she wants to allow and deny the KYC
request after the permission has been
granted then only the banks can be able
to view the KYC so if I say bank 1 allow
and bank to deny now all the requests
are done from the queue so bank one was
allowed and bank 2 was denied so if I
again log in with bank 1 and the
password is my first address view kyc
customer 1
so here it is the bank one is able to
see the details now if I log in as bank
two and give password and try to see the
it is same permission denied
so let's ask bank two to again request
now bank two is now again requesting and
now this time it allows
now bank two can see the details so all
these transactions in the back end are
happening on the blockchain network
which is interfacing with the contract
through its subsequent methods now the
primary details of the contract are in
the contract details JavaScript where we
have to provide the address at which the
contract was deployed the ABI file the
ABI so you can get the ABI at here this
is the ABI and you can paste it here and
this is the binary data
which has to be pasted over here so the
binary data can be fetched
you
from remix
you
this is the binary data for the contract
just to be copied and pasted over here
now with these essential inputs provided
our application allows us to interact in
a decentralized fashion to access the
KYC records of a particular customer now
we can modify the details also
and we can add a new customer again so
this is a basic demo of how a typical
kyc application works in a banking
environment my blockchain expert now
not quite yet there's a lot of more
information you need to learn we'll go
to that later now let's do a quick recap
so what have we learned today we learn
what is blockchain the Bitcoin story we
understood the public distributing logic
and say hash encryption the proof of
work consensus algorithm the concept of
mining and the useless of no your
customer blockchain decentralized
application which is used in banks and
the use case of rock chain in Matt's I
hope you all had a great learning
session and I'll meet you in my next
session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here